why equals 1/8 X to the third minus x
squared over which interval does y of X
have an average rate of change of 1/2 so
let's go interval by interval and
calculate the average rate of change so
first let's think about this interval
right over here between negative x is
between negative 2 & 2 so negative 2 is
less than X which is less than 2 so
let's just think about what is the value
of our function when X is equal to
negative 2 so Y of negative 2 is equal
to 1/8 times negative 2 to the third
power minus negative 2 squared which is
equal to let's see this is 1/8 of to the
3rd power is negative 8 negative 8
divided by 8 is negative 1 negative 2
squared is positive 4 but then you're
going to have to subtract that so it's
minus 4 so this is equal to negative 5
and Y of 2 y of 2 is equal to 1/8 times
2 to the 3rd power minus 2 squared minus
2 squared and that's going to be equal
to a 1 8 times 8 is 1 minus 4 which is
equal to negative 3 so if you want to
find your average rate of change you
want to figure out how much does you the
value of your function change and divide
that by how much your X Y or your X has
changed so just we could make a table
here we could make a table here X Y when
X is negative 2 y is negative 5 when X
is positive 2 y Y is negative 3 so how
much did your why change well your Y
increased your Y increased by 2 your Y
increased by 2 and your x increased by 4
your X increased by 4 and you could get
these numbers you can just look at it
the Y increased from that point to that
point X increase from that point to that
point or you could say hey negative 3
minus negative 5 is positive 2 that's
the difference between negative 3 and
negative 5 if you said
two minus negative four well that gives
you once again the distance it would get
or the difference it would give you
positive four but if you look at here
it's clear when Y increased by two or we
could say when X increased by four Y
increased by two so our average rate of
change over this interval is going to be
average average rate of change of Y with
respect to X with respect to X is going
to be equal to well when X changed by
four by positive for y changed by
positive two so it's equal to 1/2 so it
does look like the average rate of
change over this interval right over
here of this interval right over here is
1/2 so we got lucky in this situation
our first choice and this is a multiple
choice so we don't have to it's not a
multi-select here so our first one met
our criteria so we know that that's the
answer but let me do one more of these
other ones to show you why that is not
the answer
so let's find the average rate of change
between that point and that point so
let's do another let me do it in another
color so I'll do this one in purple so 0
is less than X which is less than 4 and
I'll just do the table right over here X
and y so when x is 0 what is y well it's
going to be 1/8 times 0 minus 0 y is
just going to be 0 when X is 4 what is y
well Y is going to be let's see it's
going to be 1/8 try to do this in my
head 1/8 times 4 to the 3rd 4 to the
third is 64 1/8 of 64 is 8 it's going to
be 8 minus 4 squared which is 16 8 minus
16 is negative 8 negative 8 so in this
one when we have X is increasing by 4 X
has increased by 4 what happened to why
y has decreased by 8 so the average rate
of change of Y with respect to X here is
why changed so I could write my change
in Y this Greek letter Delta just slowly
shorthand for change in
my change in Y is negative eight when my
change in X is four so the average rate
of change here is negative two it's
negative because as X increased your Y
decreased and for every on average for
every one that X increased Y decreased
by two that's where you get your
negative two here so this clearly the
average rate of change is not one-half
so that confirms that that is not the
answer and we know that these other two
and I encourage you to try them out
we'll also give you an average rate of
change of something other than positive
1/2